this tweet from labor is causing a stir
because it's suggesting that Rishi sunak
personally doesn't want to see child
abusers locked up the issue is is that
sentences are decided on by judges not
politicians and the figures date back to
2010 when Rishi sunak wasn't even an MP
that's why some in labor have said the
party should delete the tweet and accuse
them of gutter politics there is another
way of looking at this though by sending
such an inflammatory tweet labor has got
people talking about the issue of crime
under the Tories that's something they
want to focus on as they try and carve
themselves out as the party of Law and
Order in the run-up to the next general
election it's really a political tactic
straight out of the 2016 vote leave
Playbook remember that bus with that
message on the side well that was a
controversial statement but it was
designed to push at a broader point
about how much money we send to the EU
now it worked back then but I think many
will question how this fits in with Kia
stormer's vow to restore integrity and
honor to politics